[Music]
so um yep check it out open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in calvin is with us in
canada oddly enough hey calvin you're
not an attorney in canada are you
no i'm a real estate agent okay
entrepreneur got it cool how can we help
i'm looking at starting a business i'm
wondering how i can do this without a
credit score i would it's going to cost
me about 500 000 to get off the ground
and it's a advertising company it's
going to cost me i wouldn't do it that
much
you wouldn't do it nope
i wouldn't go a half million dollars in
debt to start a business
okay so how would you go about starting
an advertising company where you're
building costs for each billboard poll
is about 100 000 that you can get that
paid off with a 20 margin in two years
hypothetically
there's a rule in business
everything takes twice as long as you
think it's going to it costs twice as
much and you're not the exception
and so you've run a pro forma out on
some kind of best case scenario here
that's got you dreaming and you're
willing to take an unreasonable amount
of risk to get into this this is a story
that ends up in bankruptcy here brother
i've been doing this for 30 years and i
i started this business on a card table
in my living room and we've grown it to
300 million dollars in volume in revenue
this year with zero debt along the way
but it took a little while how would you
go about building this take a couple
years to uh save up the money to pay for
these polls and cash yep yeah yep buy
fewer of them
and boy when they start cash flowing
without any debt against them they're
going to cash flow like bandits if they
do what you're supposed to what you
think they're going to do
how do you think that it
to pull is not bad what do you make now
uh right now i'm making about 150 to 200
i've been in uh as a i've been a real
estate agent for about a year cool so
buy five polls a year
50 grand
well the the polls i'm looking at
building they're a bit larger a bit more
permanent and that's why you can charge
more for them i thought you said you
could own for 11 000 a poll
no no 100 000 a poll they
earn you 11 000 a month
oh oh oh 100 000 oh really i just wonder
calvin how did that industry do when
your prime minister literally shut the
entire country down
i mean they were still i'm not too sure
i've been looked into those statistics i
know that right now all of the areas
around calgary the companies that are in
it are expanding currently okay yeah
it's a highly speculative business
yeah i'm not borrowing 500 000 to start
buying advertising calls dude i think
you're gonna i think you're gonna you're
missing some parts of this business that
you haven't considered i can't tell what
it is in a three-minute radio call but
uh that's the answer to the question i
would save up and buy one but i'd save
up and buy another then i'd save up and
buy another and if you're making as much
money as you think you're going to make
on them you're going to cash flow your
way into a whole bunch of them within
five years